اتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
واشنطن وحلفائها للسعي للتحكم في العالم
عبر فرض نظام القطب الواحد على الجميع
وكذا الابرف ان ما سماها العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا اعطت دفعه قويه لما
وصفها بالحركه العالميه لاحلال العداله
والتعدديه وحذر من احتمال وقوع صدام مع
الغرب بسبب محاولته تعطيل ذلك التوجه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى دقه حديث لابروف عن
توجه لبناء نظام عالمي متعدد الاقطاب وعلى
اي وجه اسهمت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا في
تسريع ما سماها الحركه العالميه لاحلال
العداله والتعدديه في العالم
كذلك ما هي الدول المرشحه لتشكيل ذلك
النظام العالمي متعدد الاقطاب وعلى اي اسس
يمكن ان تبني تحالفها وما مدى توفر
العوامل المشتركه اللازمه لبناء ذلك
التحالف
واخيرا ما وجاه التحذيرات لا تضف من
امكانيه وقوع صدام عالمي وما هي فرص تجنب
وقوع ذلك الصدام في ضوء المعطيات الدوليه
الراهنه
[موسيقى]
بالتزامن مع تصعيد كبير في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ومع توسع نطاق العمليات وارتفاع
مستوى الاسلحه المستخدمه فيها وفي ظل
توترات عديده في مواقع مختلفه من العالم
يقول وزير الخارجيه الروسي فان الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها يسعون الى التحكم في
العالم عبر فرض نظام القطب الواحد على
الجميع على حد قوله ولفت الى ان تشكيل
العالم متعدد الاقطاب تقريبا وان الغرب لن
ينجح في ايقاف هذا المسار وفق قوله واضاف
انما سماها العمليه العسكريه الروسيه اعطت
دفعه قويه لما سماها الحركه العالميه
لاحلال العداله والتعدديه في العالم واوضح
وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان الغرب توهم ان
هيمتنه ان هيمنته على العالم ابديه لكنه
ايقن الان ان نهايتها باتت قريبه لاسيما
ان مسار الغرب ضد النظام العالمي متعدد
الاقطاب محفوف بحالات صدام جديده بعد فشله
في عزل روسيا بحسب
[موسيقى]
والي مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور حسن منيمنه الباحث في معهد الشرق
الاوسط في واشنطن ومن بيروت الدكتور عبد
الله الشايجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الكويت دكتور حسن دكتور عبد الله
اهلا بكما فيما وراء الخبر وابدا معك
دكتور حسن هل فعلا العالم الان يتجه لبناء
نظام
عالمي جديد متعدد الاقطاب
العالم بالفعل يتجه لبناء نظام عالمي جديد
بشكل تلقائي وليس بشكل دفع ولكن ليس عالما
متعدد الاقطاب العالم الثنائي للقطبين
نتحدث هنا عن الولايات المتحده والصين
كلام لا يعتد به
روسيا قد تقدمت باعذار مختلفه لتبرير
الاعتداء على اوكرانيا تصحيح الخطا
التاريخي حول نشوء اوكرانيا الامن الوطني
الروسي
مساعده الانفصاليين في
فيما هنالك
كلما بدا وكان الامر يستقطب المزيد من
التاييد او على الاقل يروج لمزيد من
التاييد يجري الكلام عن تعدديه قطبيه واقع
الامر بان القطب الواحد الذي شكلته
الولايات المتحده بعد سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي كان حدثا فريدا تاريخيا الى حد
ما وغير قابل للاستمرار والكلام عن نهايه
نظام القطب الواحد هو كلام دائر منذ قرابه
ربع القرن من الزمن وحقيقه الامر بان
التوقعات كانت ولا تزال بانه سوف ينتهي
لقد تاخر انتهائه ولكن ليس باتجاه تعدديه
قطبيه كما يريد ان يؤكد
وزير الخارجيه الروسي بل باتجاه ثنائيه
قطبيه مع الصين
اذا بالنسبه قد تكون له اسباب في هذه
الكلام ولكن دكتور الشايجي هل توافقه في
طرحه في توجهه هل هناك ادله او شواهد تذهب
باتجاه ذلك سواء كنا نتحدث عن تعدديه
قطبيه ام ثنائيه قطبيه
لا يعني انا من 2014 تقريبا وادرس طلبتي
في جامعه الكويت باننا بناء على الدراسات
الامريكيه نفسها لمجلس الاستخبارات الوطني
وكذلك الوثائق التي تصدرها وزاره الدفاع
ومجلس الامن الوطني الامريكي الامريكان
نفسهم يتكلمون اننا نحن متجهين الى نظام
متعدد الاقطاب مالتي بولر وهذا النظام
يشمل صعود دول تراجع امريكا كقوه عظمى
يعني بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه كانت
امريكا تنتج 50% من مجمل الناتج القومي
العالمي الكلي الان تنتج اقل من 25% فواضح
ان هناك في تراجع للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه منذ منذ سنوات في صعود لقوى
اخرى على راسها الصين روسيا تتحدى ولكن
روسيا اقتصاد لا يسمح لها ان تكون دوله
سوبر باور عظمى الص هي كما يقول دائما
التقارير التي تصدرها الحكومه الامريكيه
سنويا هي اكبر تحدي للهيمنه الامريكيه على
المستوى الدوري
قضيه امريكا مقابل الصين هذا ما نتحدث عنه
اكيد
يذهب باتجاه اخر
طبعا يعني عندها يعني انا متابع في كل
مناسبه وكل قمه واخرها في البريكس وقبلها
في لاتن امريكا واليوم في حتى في
اندونيسيا عندما ذهب اليها وتصريح اليوم
هو مكرر يعني دائما روسيا تريد ان تقدم
نفسها ان هي ضحيه وتواجه الغرب وتواجه
النيتو ولكن روسيا هي التي هاجمت وهي التي
غزت وهي التي تشن حرفا على اوكرانيا هي
وقعت في فخ من صنعها فلهذا السبب يسعى الى
فروض وبوتين لان يشكلوا نوعا من لعبه
الضحيه واننا نحن نواجه الغرب باكمله
ليتامر علينا ويريد ان يمنعنا
في بريكس يعني كان واضح جدا
منفصل ولكن يعني اذا كان هذا هو المقصود
بكلام ما مصلحه روسيا اذا ان تستبدل سيدا
بسيد تستبدل الولايات المتحده بالصين ربما
اترك الفرصه للدكتور على هذا السؤال
لا وقع العمر ليس استبدال الولايات
المتحده بالصين ولكن التعويل على الصين
واخرين خلال فتره الصعود الصيني مجددا
الموقف امريكيا التقارير التي يشير اليها
الزميل اي القراءات الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه للواقع المقبل هي باننا نشهد
صعودا للصين تريد الولايات المتحده ان
يكون صعودا هادئا وان يبقى في اطار النفود
الاقتصادي والا يصرف عسكريا مقابل هبوط
لروسيا والولايات المتحده كانت تتمنى ان
يكون هذا الهبوط هبوط هادئ والا يصرف
عسكريا كذلك ولكن روسيه
هاجمت اوكرانيا وحاولت ان تستفيد من فائض
القوه المتوفر لها حاليا والذي هو الى
اضمحلال في المرحله المقبله للقيام
بمغامره ولكن القراءه من وجهه نظر الروسيه
هي التعويل على انه خلال هذا الانتقال كما
تمكنت روسيه فعليا من الاستفاده من الواقع
السوري لاعاده التموضع في الاوسط في حين
الجميع اعتبر بانها قد افلت كقوه خارج
نطاق الاطار الجغرافي الخاص بها فانه
لربما قد تتمكن خلال هذا الصعود الصيني من
نوع من الاصطفاف ولكن علينا ان نلاحظ هنا
لان الحديث عن تعدديه قطبيه هو حديث روسي
دائم وليس حديثا صينيا مثلا رغم انه في
بعض الاحيان تشير الصين الى ذلك ولكن
التنافس الصيني الروسي قائم في اسيا
الوسطى قائم في اكثر من موقع اذا نعم هي
نوع من المشاغبه الروسيه اليوم من اجل
التعكير على التصوير الواقع لان روسيا
مشاغبه في الواقع دكتور عبد الله هي
مشابهه ليست جديده وكما قلت انت نفسك يعني
لسنوات كثير من المحللين يتحدثون عن عالم
متعدد الاقطاب سياتي ولكن يقول انه سياتي
قريبا
والسبب ليس سوريا وانما الحرب الاوكرانيه
والطريقه التي تم التعامل بها هل فعلا
نجحت روسيا في استقطاب بعض الدول في هذه
المواجهه مع الغرب تحديدا يعني ما هي
الدول هذه التي يمكن القول عنها انها نجحت
اذا كانت
يعني هي دول بنايات الامر غير ديمقراطيه
وفاشله وليست نموذجا يتبع اذا يعني تابعنا
تصويتين كان في
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في شهر مارس
2022 بعد شهر من غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا 142
دوله صوتت ضد روسيا ضد غزوها وطالبتها
بالانسحاب بعد سنه من
الاحتلال الروسي او الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا 144 دوله صوتوا ضد طالب روسيا
بالانسحاب بلا شرط من بما فيهم من
اوكرانيا بما فيهم حلفاء روسيا بما فيها
الصين امتنعت يعني بنهايه الامر منحلفاء
روسيا بنهايه الامر يشكلون هذا التعدديه
القطبيه بالنسبه لروسيا كوريا الشماليه
سوريا هل تفتخر انت بهذه الحلفاء حتى
حلفاء الحلفاء المتوقع يكون استراتيجين
على راسها الصين امتنع التصويت يعني في
هناك يعني مبالغات كبيره من روسيا مثل ما
ذكرت روسيا لا تملك الكثير من القدره على
الاقناع يعني روسيا متورطه بشكل كبير في
اوكرانيا بعد سنه ونصف من الحرب والحين
دخلنا الشهر التاسع عشر روسيا لم تحقق اي
من اهدافها الاستراتيجيه في ورطه كبيره
صار في تمرد من وشفنا شلون انتهى روسيا في
وضع اقتصادي صعب الروبل الانهار بشكل كبير
امام الدولار والعملات
الصعبه فروسيا لا تقدم نفسها نموذجا مقنعا
لان تكون هي راعيه هذه التعدديه القطبيه
وكذلك الصين يعني امريكا في الحرب البارده
نجحت بمنع تحالف شيوعي شيوعي روسيا
سوفياتي صيني ضد الولايات المتحده
باستراتيجيه الاحتواء والرول باك
والكونتينمنت والتي نجحت فيها بازعاج
وبانهاك وباستنزاف روسيا حتى سقط الاتحاد
السوفيتي والان نفس الشيء يتكرر يعني
امريكا هدفا الاستراتيجي هو منع تحالف
روسي صيني يكون هو يعني المحور الرئيسي
لنظام متعدده امريكا تريد ان تعيق هذا
التحالف وليس لا يمكنه وهذه نقطه اتفق
فيها يعني نحن متجهين بشكل واضح متعلمين
عند نقطه نقطه تتعلق يعني ما جاء في كلمه
انه محاوله
هناك دفعه لحركه عالميه باتجاه احلال
العداله والتعدديه وهذه
الروح او الورقه بدانا يعني بدات تنتشر
بشكل كبير في اجزاء كبيره ممكن تكون دكتور
حسن مثل ما قال الدكتور عبد الله في دول
ربما ليست يعني لها ذلك النفوذ او القوه
لاننا نعرف ان القطب حتى يتشكل لابد ان
يكون له اقتصاد قوي لابد ان يكون له نفوذ
سياسي لابد ان يكون له قوه عسكريه عالميه
هل هناك في اي من هذه الدول هل هناك هل
هناك دوله قادره فعلا تقدم نفسها كذلك
الصين حتى وان لم تقدم نفسك كذلك هل هي
قادره فعلا ام يجب ان يكون هناك توحد يجب
ان يكون هناك كيان يشمل اكثر من من دوله
لا واقع الامر مجددا كلام ياتي في اطار
ترويجي محض اي انه لا يمكن لا يمكن ان
يعتاد به ولكن حتى اذا عندما يحاول الحديث
حتى لاعلام الموالي لروسيا غالبا ويحاول
الحديث في المرحله وكان افريقيا تنطفد على
الاستعمار واقع الامر بان عندما نتحدث عن
انتفاض افريقي هنا بعض الانقلابات
العسكريه غير التي لا يمكن وصفها على
الاطلاق بانها حركات شعبيه على اي حال بغض
النظر عن حشد بعض المؤيدين هنا وهنالك من
هي هذه الجهه الداعيه الى العداله الدوليه
اي تعداله هي التي تسعى روسيا الى تحقيقها
من خلال الغزو والتدمير والقتل في في
اوكرانيا ومن من خلال مسانده نظام قاتل
كما النظام في في سوريا مثلا ثم مسانده
في هذه النقطه ان ايضا الطرف الاخر مثل
الولايات المتحده ومن تمثله ايضا ارتكب
جرائم بحق الديمقراطيه في عدد من الدول
العالم
ولكن ليس هناك من يزعم بانه هناك حركه
دوليه مؤيده للغرب اليوم دفعا لتحقيق
المفهوم العداله هو ربما ما يلعب عليه
لافروف هنا وهذا ربما
المضمون الذي يقدمه ليس مقنعا على الاطلاق
وحتى محاوله الحديث عن الاستعمار الغربي
الاستعمار الفرنسي البريطاني مثلا
لافريقيا نعم روسيا لم تستعمل في افريقيا
ولكنها استعمرت في اسيا الوسطى وفي
سيبيريا وصولا الى
قاهر الشرقاز بمعنى قائر القوقاز والصين
كذلك لم تستعمر في افريقيا ولكنها استعمرت
في التيبات واستعمرت في تركستان الشرقيه
ونشهد ما يجري اليوم ليس اذا اذا هنا
رفع الشعار العداله الدوليه بطبيعه الحال
هو شعار هو رفع ترويجي وليس قائم على على
مساله جديه مجددا اقول ليس ان العالم لن
يكون هناك اقطاب اخرى غير غير
القطبين الصيني والامريكي ولكن هذه اقطاب
اقل اقل وزنا نستطيع ان نتحدث مثلا طبعا
عن الاتحاد الاوروبي عن الهند الصاعده
والتي قد تتمكن بفعل الحجم الاقتصادي من
ان تصل الى الى ان تصل الى مصاف القطب
كذلك
طبيعه الحال ولكن نحن
امثله جيده
قبل قليل دكتور عبد الله يعني انت تتحدث
عن اصلا تشكل من اجل كسر يعني هذا كان
الرؤيه انه يكسر الهيمنه الاقتصاديه الان
هل فعلا هناك امكانيه لكي يلعب دور اكبر
في هذا الاطار
ام ماذا
صحيح يعني البريكس طبعا
حتى المصطلح هو غربي يعني
اختصار لاسم خمس دول وبرازيل روسيا الهند
الصين وجنوب افريقيا وهو اخترعه او اللفه
يعني اقتصادي بريطاني يعمل في في احد
البنوك الامريكيه والان توسع صار اضافه ست
دول اخرى صار 11 دوله يشكل 42% من يعني
اصدار
انتاج النفط يشكل كتله بشريه كبيره وهدفه
هي العداله وان يكون هناك تمثيل افضل
وطبعا يعني جذاب هو رساله بريكس بنهايه
الامر اللي هي تريد ان تكون نظاما بديلا
للهيمنه والنظام الغربي الاسلامي متجانس
بما يكفي ويقدم نفسه نعم الامر غير متجانس
عليه هي القصه
ليس نموذجا صحيح ملفت للدول الناميه التي
تريد ان تتحرر من النفوذ والهيمنه الغربيه
والورد بنك
والنظام الغربي بقياده امريكا واوروبا
والنيتو ولكن بنايات الامر يعني القدره
محدوده ولكن حتى الدولار يعني يوجد تفاوت
بدا الان التعامل باليوان الصيني دول
الخليج بدات ان تتقرب عندنا الان دولتين
خليجيتين وعندنا مصر انضمت والامارات
والسعوديه هو تثقيل لهذه الدول وارسال
رساله لامريكا بالدرجه الاولى ان عندنا
خيارات اخرى وهذا جزء من اللعبه الذكيه
التي تلعبها الدول الاقتصاديات الناشئه
بقياده الصين يعني حتى
جون ادم اعتقد اسما اللي هو صاحب هذه
الفكره ذكر بانه كان انا اخطات كان مفروض
اسميها اي سي اللي هي الهند هندي ان
تشاينا او الافضل كان الصين يعني هؤلاء
فريق رايدرز يعني روسيا وج افريقيا صاحبه
اقتصاد اقل بعدين ما في عداله يعني لماذا
لم تنضم نيجيريا مثلا
العشرين وانضمت اثيوبيا الفقيره
الاقتصادها 160 مليار دولار يعني في يعني
غير مقنع
الشروط واليه انضمام الدول لهذه المجموعه
التي بالفعل يعني لها مستقبل ولكن الان لا
تشكل تهديدا وهذا الذي ذكر اليوم البيت
الابيض لا تشكر تهديدا للامن القومي
الامريكي ولكن تزعجي وتقدم نموذجا قد يكون
جذابا في المستقبل اذا نجحت بان يصير
عندنا يعني بنك دكتور عبد الله اقتصادي
وتنموي وكذلك ان تؤثر على الدولار يتراجع
تماما
والصين اللي يحكمهم الحزب الشيوعي
اقتصادهم يخضع لقوانين السوق والراسماليه
الدكتور حسن في النهايه
يقول انه يريد لا يبني لا تبنى سياسات
روسيا على ان تكون ضد الغرب وضد الولايات
المتحده
اذا روسيا لا يحكمها الحزب الشيوعي
ولكن طبعا ولكن ما يجري ما يجري حاليا
باتجاه يعني بعد على انقاذ الاتحاد
السوفيتي وليس له اي كيان يعني مستقل وهذا
هو ربما الدافع لكي
يثير اعتقد بانه من الخطا اعتبار وكانها
اعاده انشاء لكتله مواجهه للغرب
بالشكل الذي كانت عليه الكتله الاشتراكيه
ليس هذا هو الواقع ليس فقط لعدم التجانس
على مستوى مكونات البريكس ولكن كذلك
للتداخل لبلان ربما معظم اعضاء البريكس هم
في البريكس للتنويع وليسوا في البريكس
للحصريه اي انا عندما نتحدث عن الهند مثلا
التي هي جزء من الرباعيه المطوقه للصين
اذا الهند والصين هما في البريكس
الهند جزء رباعيه مع الولايات المتحده
واستراليا واليابان لضمان عدم اذا شئت
وصول النفوذ الصيني الى ما يهدد
الجوار في المحيطين الهادي والهند اذا
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه للعديد من الدول التي
ربما سارعت التي ربما طلبت الانضمام الى
الهدف هنا ليس الحصريه بقدر ما هو
المناوره والتنويع ومن حق هذه الدول
بطبيعه الحال اتحدث مثلا هنا عن السعوديه
تحديدا من حقها ان تنوع وان تناور لان
علينا ان نتذكر بان
الشراكه التي كانت قائمه بين السعوديه
والولايات المتحده على اساس حمايه
اقتصاديه والمساهمه في حمايه اقتصاديه من
جانب الولايات من جانب السعوديه للولايات
المتحده مقابل حمايه امنيه من جانب
الولايات المتحده للسعوديه واذ بعد ضربه
ارامكو يتبين مع الرئيس ترامبس صاحب
العضلات الكبيره بان انتم وحالكم وحالكم
اذا لا بد للسعوديه من السعي الى صيغ
مختلفه بما في ذلك
التحالفات الجديده
نقطه مهمه جدا
المساله هي بان ثروه الصين بالدولار ودين
الولايات المتحده بالدولار على الاقل جزء
كبير منه في الحالتين وبالتالي الحديث عن
ان بريكس هو مقابل الدولار لابد من تلطيف
هذا المبدا طبعا
اريد ان انتقل الى نقطه اخرى تتعلق بتحذير
ليلابروف دكتور عبد الله الشايجي من ان
هناك محاوله من الغرب لتعطيل هذه
او بناء النظام العالمي الجديد مواقعيه
هذا التحذير وخصوصا انه يتزامن مع
مستوى تسليح غربي لاوكرانيا غير مسبوق
يعني لحد ما صحيحه امريكا استراتيجيتها
واضحه اعاقه وتاخير وصول الصين الى تكون
قوه منافسه تؤثر على الهيمنه الغربيه
بالدرجه الاولى وامريكا تقدم يعني ثلاثه
انواع من القوه القوه الناعمه والقوه
الخشنه العسكريه لاكبر ميزانيه عسكريه في
تاريخ البشريه اكثر من 850 مليار دولار
اللي هي ثلاثه ارباع الاقتصاد الروسي يعني
من هذا المنطلق صحيح ان هناك في مسعى ولكن
امريكا تعلم والغرب يعلم والعالم يعلم
وهذه سنه الامبراطوريات والقوى العظمى
انها لن تكون هي التي تجلس على العرش
متفرده هناك قوه صاعده مؤثره
ولهذا السبب امريكا تعلم ذلك ولكن لا تريد
للنموذج الصيني الشيوعي الذي يحكم به
الرئيس مدى الحياه والذي لا تقدم الصين
سوفت باور كثيره ان تكون هي النموذج التي
يقنع الدول الناميه ان هي النموذج الناشئه
لهذا السبب بريكس هي الاسلوب والطريقه
التي من خلالها روسيا والصين يريدان ان
يقنعان النظام العالمي والدول يعني في
الناميه بان انضمامكم الينا يسرع في اضعاف
الغرب ويجعلنا نحن النموذج البديل المقنع
لكم الدكتور عبدالله الشايجي استاذ ذا
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت كنت معنا
من بيروت وشكرا للدكتور حسن النمنم الباحث
في معهد الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن معنى من
واشنطن وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء القمر في
[موسيقى]